O zaman mutlu oluyoruz ya da nasıl
hissediyoruz şimdi burada bir görevini
yerine getirmem lazım Çünkü bir selam
girsin ozanı izin dergimizin yine
bakalım bu derginin adı onun editörüdür
benim 2dönem üstümde o zaman dedim bugün
konuşma yapacağımızı lütfen başta Twitch
ve Altınsoy olmak üzere bütün herkese
benim selamlarımı ilet lütfen Bunu
söyleyerek başlıkları dedi Ben de göre
bilinciyle bununla başladım onbaşımı
düşündük yani alan dayken o sırada o
alanı hissederken hissedilmeyen ya da
hakkını veremediğimiz bir duygu yıllar
sonra ya da bir dönem sonra nasıl bu
kadar tatlı nasıl bu kadar güzel
Hatırlamıyor Peki mutluluğu neden o anda
o kadar güzel yaşayamıyoruz bunu bunu
sorgulama
Sen oradan da aslında şöyle buradan
Birazcık değil yol haklarına gireceğim
bir kaçta anımı anlatacağım mutlulukla
yapılan çalışmalarda şöyle bir şey var
mutluluk gerçekten sonradan Hatırlamıyor
insanlara demişler ki bir an yaşıyorlar
Mutlular o anda skoryum diyorlar Hadi
1'den 10'a kadar mesela sporlarını puan
verin mutlu olduğunuzu bir puan veriyor
sonradan zaman geçiyor diyorlar ki
tekrar puanı skoru 1'den 10'a kadar
görülmüş ki bilimsel olarak işte emarla
da testler ya da bu ispatlıyor
hastalığın algıları da ölçülüyor
görülmüş ki insanlar Belli bir zaman
geçtikten sonra çok yüksek oranda çok
bitmedi daha yüksek skorlar Çünkü bunu
sanırım sindirilmesi için ve bazı
parasız parasız parazitlerinde yok
edilmesi alanlar çıkarılması için
rengini zaman gerekiyor Bu da Aslı
Evet Ee öğrenerek elde edilmiş bir şey
yani nasıl mutlu olacağımızı neye
güleceğiz de hepsini öğreniyoruz bir
bakıma bir bebek doğduğunda şanslı
sahnesini kucağına veriyor 86 saat sonra
Eğer anne kavramı yoksa annelik Yapacak
başka birinin kucağında veriyor ve siz
onu kucağına verdiğinizde annenizin
gülümsemesiyle karşılaşıyoruz Yani ilk
gördüğünüz şey beni gördü Demek ki buna
mutlu oluyor ya da şu bir şey
söylediğinizde bir kelime ilk defa
söylediğiniz etrafınız biliyor Demek ki
bu güzel bir şey devam etmeliyim bunu
yapmaya devam ediyorsunuz bir çocuk
küfür ettiğinde siz biliyorsanız o çocuk
küfür etmenin etrafını güldüren bir şey
olduğunu düşünüyor Çünkü zevk yol
haklarıyla alakalı ve aynı zamanda
hepsini temelinde hayatta kalma içgüdüsü
var şimdi buradan tekrar bir mutluluk
ismine geri döneyim mutluluk Aslında en
çok olduğu zaman kabullenmekle alakalı
web
Bir de bizim doğuştan getirdiğimiz bir
yetenek işe bebek yağı gibi buna nüfus
Network geliyor Yani siz olduğumuz almak
bu şekilde kabul ediyorsunuz Şimdi
genelde hep böyle bir zaman kazanma
telaşı mız var bir yerlere yetişelim
zaman kazanalım ev daha kolay öğrenelim
ya da işte yarın sınavımız var ama o
sırada da bir arkadaşım sizi kahve
içmeye çağırdı ya da bir çok güzel bir
film var bir daha izleyeceksiniz gibi
bir zaman kazanma telaşı mız var o filmi
izlemeyin ya da işte O kahveyi
arkadaşımla içmeyeyim gibi insan bir
yola gidiyor bir yerlerden zaman
tasarrufu yapmaya çalışıyor e o an çünkü
geleceği odaklıyız yani yarınki gün
sonraki sınava odaklıyız ve o anda
yaşadığımız her şey zaman kaybı gibi
geliyor aynı şöyle Ben dedim işte biraz
karar zorda vereceğim şey ortaokuldan
sonra
bu çalışacağım da görünce gayet göre
bilinciyle Yani hep bir fazla sorumluluk
ihtiyacı vardır niye annemler çalışıyor
acaba ne kadar maaş alıyor ve benim
bütün defterlerini Kitaplarımı alıyorlar
ve istedikleri Benim mutlu olmam iyi
olmaz Benim de bunu iyi yapamadım
çalışmam lazım yapıştay Diğer görevlere
adamı gibi gibi bir halin vardı
ortaokuldan sonra lise sınavları Hep de
böyle bir şeyleri Kıl payı yetiştim
Dedem sayesinde ben beş yaşında iki kat
tad almış apartmanda oturuyoruz okul
yolu evin önünden geçip Ben balkondan
düşen mavi örnek yiyeceğim ağabey örnek
yiyeceğim diye o an Bildiğim tek şey
mavi önünün Beni mutlu et şey yani bütün
hayatını Ondan ibaret sonra beni götürdü
ben erken başladığım için her şey böyle
kıl payı yetiştim lise sınavları da oldu
bitti benim aklımda Tabi ya Öyle bir şey
yok evdeyim mutluyum bu mutluluk
kodlarım varmış de akşam şey haberler aç
oy verdi sarı bez alıp masayı silerim
işte salatayı Ben geçiyor bunlar böyle
birşey mutluluk olarak kodlanmış beynin
ödül yolakları çalıştırıyor e o sıradışı
Haber geldi derdim Fen Lisesi'ni
kazanmışım bir taraftan çok güzel bir
şey bir taraftan herkesin böyle birşey
Nutku tutuldu bu çocuk 14 yaşında zaten
fotosentez yapıyor gibi gıcık bir şey
hani şimdi yatılı mı kalsın Biz her gün
akşam hergün akşam yolda yürü gel yürü
gel işte çay iç kahve iç ne yapsak Evet
şey gitmem lazım tabi ilim bilim Ama
şöyle bak yemene içmene dikkat et bak
uykularına Dikkat et gibi neyse Biz şey
ben Aydın Fen Lisesi'ne başladım ama
gelin uğurlaması gibi Yani her şey çok
böyle anlamlı duygu yüklü bir liste var
işte pembe çarşafı mız olsun pembe
yastıklarımız olsun o sevgi listeden
böyle Pick yapıyoruz işte her şeyin
pembe ol
O biraz pembe ben bıkmadım bir şey
itiraf edeyim alanlar geliyorlar bütün
ayrı geliyorlar böyle uğurlama gelin
uğurlaması gibi beni Aydın herkesin
Valizini vuruyorlar ben de işte hafta
sonlarını iple çekiyorum Yani öyle bir
dönem ama bir taraftan da olduğunu
derinleştirdi yandı bir içine döndüm Bu
arada bir insan ne ile mutlu olduğunu
nasıl mutlu olduğunu daha iyi anlıyor ya
bazı şeyleri toplamışım ve o küçük Kay
mutlu bir çocukluk yaşadığım için
büyümeye güvenli hale oldu yani babamla
Bizim Şarkımız kaygı Çünkü biz büyüdük
ve kirlendi dünya onu verecek diye bir
korku diye biçimi ya Demek ki benim
böyle kalmam lazım burada kalayım Sonra
işte biraz daha ha ilerledi ve lise 1'de
öğretmenlerim arkadaşlarım biraz daha
insan açılmaya başlıyor eğer o anda hep
böyle bir şeyler ye
Bu ne la şimdi vardı Çünkü bazı şeyleri
Sanki zor öğreniyor muşum gibi
hissediyorum kendimde yazıyordum şimdi
dikkatimi toplamaya çalışıyordum Sanki
dünyada bir tane öğrenecek şey vardı
Hani ben Allahım olur da iki saat fazla
uyursam bu görevini işte misyonunu
yerine getiremem gibi bir halin vardı ve
o sırada ya kendim de fark ettiğim şey
hala daha çözmeye çalıştım şey seneler
sonra ben bunu farkettim camdan dışarı
bak mesela bahçedeki O bizim Ozan
ağacımızı bakmak diyelim ki onlar gün
sonra düşündüğünde ne yaptım ben acaba
diye ne yaptım işte yapmam gereken iş
sistemi yapmadım ama camdan dışarı
baktım ben Yani az hiçbir şey yapmadım
kendimi suçluyorum Sonra Seher sonra ben
bunu anladım ki aslında görev gibi
yapıyormuş ve gerçekte Noel çalıştığınız
en yoğun çalıştığını andaki beyninizin
at
bu kıyasla Aslında beynin en aktif
olduğu ve bütün değil merkezleri
arasındaki gidiş geliş yollarını en
aktif olduğu dönem sizin beyninizde
default Network diye bir şebekeyi ateşle
dediğiniz İşte bu hiçbir şey
yapmadığımız Belki de canının
sıkıldığını sandığımız bu dökmüş O
yüzden o zamanlar ben zaman kazanmaya
çalışıyorum işte bir program olur Mesela
işte basket maçı olur ya da dışarıda bir
piknik olur oraya gidiyordum gerçekten
mutlu olmaya çalışıyorum ama içinden de
bir ses gidiyor zaman yani bir şeyler
yapman lazım senin bu şekilde o zaman
hiç uyumam lazım gibi böyle bir savunma
mekanizması geliştiriyor du bu default
Network denilen şey aslında sıkılmanın
mucizevi bir şekilde beyinde yarattığı
bir ateşleme en aktif olan hali dikkat
ederseniz diyelim ki beze
Ne yapıyorsunuz ya da çamaşırlar yıkandı
kaplanca Ya da ben daha güzelini
söyleyeyim çorap kaplamak Hayatımda en
sevdiğim şey ve şey ise de hafta sonları
eve gittiğimde Tabii ki hiçbir şey yani
bütün herşeyiniz götürüyorsunuz
çamaşırlarınızı bütün ihtiyaçlarınızı
götürüyorsunuz sıfır geliyorsunuz elbise
seferinde ben 36 çift çorap götürmüştüm
herhalde Bir hafta kaldım ya Nasıl oldu
Hiçbir fikrim yoktu makinede yıkanıyor
diye ben orada Onları güzelce böyle
saklamışım Hani evde olması gereken bir
şey gibi Anneannem O zaman şey gümüştür
çocuğum Ben yurtta arkadaşlarımıza
çoraplarını getiriyorsun yani getiriyor
San getir Ne yapalım yaparız Ama evde
oturup böyle herkes çorap kaplıyor şimdi
o zaman kaybı gibi öğlen anladı bezelye
yıkadığınız anda çorap kapladığımız işte
böyle içi yaptığınız zaman sonra o
sırada hiçbir şey düşünmediğini sana
ve Bebeğinizin en aktif olduğu anlar ve
çok güzel fikirler yaratıcı fikirler ve
bu anlarda devreye giriyor ve Bu alanın
bu şebekenin vücudumuza sorumlu olduğu
beynimizde sorumlu oldu Başka bir şey
daha var kabullenme almış Çünkü
olduğumuz an kabullenip mutluluk
üretiyorsunuz şöyle gibi mesela Eşim
beynimizde bir ön taraf var bizim
yürütücü işlevleri mizin karar vermeden
muhakeme den sorumlu bugün benim diyen
bir Makina bir bilgisayar e saniyede
yüzlerce işlem yapsa bile Ebu muhakeme-i
duyguları aynalık değerlendirme dediği
için hiçbir zaman beyinden Üstün değil
Bunu belki söyleyebilir sadece
makineleri eğitmeye çalışıyoruz işte
insan beyni gibi olsun ki muhakeme
yeteneği olsun diye iki merkez gibi
düşünebiliriz çok süper özetleyecek
olursam de yine ve ön tarafta karar
veren kritik şeyleri söyleyen işte
toplumun baskısını insanlar ne der
Elalem ne
ne yapmalıyım nasıl çalışmanın karar
veren merkezler şöyle gibi beyninizi
şöyle ön taraf beynimizde ön kısmı
şurada böyle üste katlanan bir kısımlar
bu bölgenin altı Burası biraz Lara
ayrılabilen bir kısım beyin
cerrahlarının Hatta daha rahat ayrılıyor
Burası Hard diskin yani belleğiniz
içerde limbik sistemden elin zevklerden
Duygulardan sorumlu olan alıp ve beyin
her yerinde böyle önlü arkalı yollar var
Yani şöyle bir 100 milyon milyon 100
milyar da trilyondan fazla sinir üzerine
arasında bağlantılar var ve elimizde bir
terazi gibi düşünün kabullenme hali ve
korka çay var şimdi bu default şerbetin
Siz ateşlediğini zaman vücut kabullenme
halinde oluyor ama o içerideki Elin bir
sistem
LOL bebeklerden sorumlu olmak istemem
birazcık evin alt benlik gibi düşünüp
bir şey ben sıkıldığımda ve kaç diyor
Biz Core kaç moduna girdiğinizde bütün
hatalar yüzünüze daha çıkıyor insandan
soğumaya başladığınızda üzerinde tehdit
istediğinizde sizin temelinde bu hayatta
kalma içgüdüsü yer mutsuz oluyorsunuz
bir şekilde hayatımızı devam
ettiriyorsun hep böyle hayatta kalma
telaşı var bu Korkular size kaç git
diyen Korkular zevk vermeyen için yok şu
Aradaki dengeyi sağlamak gerekiyor Bir
taraftan da diğer şebeke bu kısmı
bastırıp yasla Burası da güzel demeye
çalışıyorsun Mesela bir yolda
gidiyorsunuz 3 şeritli Yolda Sol şey
takıyor ve siz ortasının yetişmemiz
lazım o zaman ya
o için sonuçları da geçmeye
çalışıyorsunuz bütün bakmıyor sonra sol
şekilde bir türlü böyle dakikalar sonra
geçtiğimizde bir bakıyorsunuz atmaya
başladı Çünkü o zaman ben niye bu tarafa
geçtim diye bu sefer bir üzülmeye
başlıyorsun zaman kaybettim Nasıl bunu
bilemezsin diye nüfus Network işi bu
şebeke denilen şey o an için olduğunuz
durumla barışma Doğanlı kabullenmeyi
sağlıyor mutlulukla öyle bir şey hani
artık çevrimiçi çevrimdışı kavramların
kullanmaya başladık çevrimiçi Yaşamak
için bir mutluluğu anda kabullenmek her
şeyin de hissetmek ve bu kaç iç kısmını
birazcık görüntülemek birazcık orada
kalmak ve yani şekilleri açmak direk
şimdi zor kabullenme aynı zamanda
beyinde bazı dolaplarını de Çünkü
ediyorsunuz şiir
Evet şu an ben olduğu yerde mutluyum bir
şey gibi sonra oturduğunuz düşünün
[Müzik]
arkadaşınız Aslında görmüyorsunuz ve
sahneyi gibi tiyatroda arada bir saat
geç olduğunuz yere alışıyorsun zaten
benim burada devam edebilirim gibi
düşünmeye başladınız mı konuşuyorsunuz
bizim işte bunları tutturma ulaşmamızı
sağlayan hayata devam etmenizi sağlayan
şey bu ip oznet bu Şebeke yok o yüzden
dışarı bakmaktan zevk alıyorsun hiçbir
şey yapmıyorsunuz o gün arkadaşınıza
sadece sohbet edeceksiniz bu yapın Çünkü
gerçekten beyniniz exito sırada oluyor
şimdi kabullenmek ve artı larımızı
farketmek bu beyinde gerçekten ödül
dolapları devreye sokan bir şey bu ödül
mekanizması devreye girdiğinde bir
tatmin duygusu oluştuğunda sizin Demek
ki ben bundan sonrasında devam
edebilirim gibi savaşçı ruhumuz devreye
giriyor
de söyleyebilirim Ne oldu Biz bunu
kolaylaştırmak için ve tabii bazı
şeylere dikkat etmemiz getirdiğimizde
nelere dikkat edin şu anda çevrimiçi
mutluluğu yaşayalım bir kere yaşam amacı
olması en önemli şey yapılan
çalışmalarda bu ispatlanmış Bu sadece ve
sadece varoluş bile olsa ya da
gittiğiniz her yerde çiçek açmak bile
olsa sadece varlığınızla bundan memnun
olup bunu onurlandırmak ve ödüller seni
devreye sokmak gerekiyor birazcık şey
çok sorularda geldi asmaya ay vermeye
devam Nasıl oluyor nelere dikkat edelim
beynimizde gibi şimdi artık ve diğer
dans vardı şöyle bir ortak nokta devasa
Aslında tarif işte metal dedim de
bilişsel akıllı alakalı de ikide onun
olmadı bulamaz bulamaz hastaneye giden
buradan hızlandı ya
ve genetik faktörler de olabiliyor ya
neden hiç bilmediğiniz şeyler oluyor
Bazı şeylerin önüne geçemiyoruz ama
vücudumuza hazırlayarak beynimize
hazırlayarak bunları birazcık zamana
yaymak ve sağlıklı ömür yaşamak mümkün
şöyle bir kısacık anlattım sonra geriye
dönüp nelere dikkat edelim diye
söyleyeceğim Bu hastalıklarda yani
hastaneden hastalıklarda beyinde bazı
proteinler birikiyor Aslında pişmiş
proteinlerle oldu öğrenmekte protein
oldu bir çocuk suyu elini değdiğinde
çektiğinde her protein sentezini aynı
işi küfür ettiğinde sezona güldüğümüzde
onda o duymuyor haklarıdır Bizim de onu
o davranış öğreniliyor neye mutlu
olacağım Nereye gideceğimize başta
öğreniyor birazcık yöneticide
getiriyoruz ama nasıl tepkiler verdiğini
duygularımızı nasıl yönettiğiniz
öğreniyor yani burada her şey Kamu Spotu
gibi oldu etrafımızı Gerçekten güzel
seçimi işte bu
bu ön tarafını karar verme mekanizmasını
sağlayan merkezin gelişmesi 20'li
yaşlara kadar çok ciddi bir şekilde
devam ediyor O yüzden bu lise
dönemindeki şeyler sizi destekleyenler
önünü açan var Özgür bırakanlar etrafı
Çok önemli çünkü ne hissettiğinizi bir
Aslında öğreniyorsun ne nasıl
öğreneceğinizi öreceğim bu senteziyle
oluyor ve hücre düşün biyoloji
derslerinden hücre hatırlarsınız daha
ekleniyor ikisinin arasına bir tane
boşluklar bir tane varmış Bunu Sinop
istiyoruz Aslında şimdi öğrenci olduğunu
bir tane protein sentezini diyelim çok
basit haliyle bu kimyasal yazıyor
toplanıyor Siz bunu başka şeylerle
ilişkilendirebilirsiniz duygularınızla o
anı bir heyecan katarsınız Mutlu
Allah sizi öfke katarsın 16 tane çok
temel duygumuz varsa öfke nefret
tiksinme Mutluluk üzüntü şaşırma gibi
Azab için duyguları beni tolerans
gelişir çok ilginç bir çikolatayı parça
yiyorsunuz sonra yediniz aynı hissi
yaratıyor sizde ya da üzüntü sürücünüzün
nereye kadar yapıp sonra biraz daha
alıyoruz burada ufacık senin beynin
parası geliştirme dediği asla tek Duygu
çok böyle bütün ayrıntıları yapacağım
ama çok net bir şey gibi oluyor mu evet
şaşırma duygusu O yüzden sevdiklerini
sürpriz yapın Çünkü E bu sürprizler olan
ki duygular onu öğrenilen şeyler
gerçekten beyindeki Hücreler arası
bağlantı yaptırıyor şimdi şey
öğrendiklerim kimyasal bir Reaksiyon
ikisinin hücresi arasında maddeler
sağlığını proteinler sağlandı bunu
tekrarladığımız
mı başka şeylerle ilişkilendirildiği
nizde Eğer bir tutkunuz var Sana Gönül
verdiyseniz bu bir şekilde başka bir
yerde ilişkilendirir Seniz bunu değil mi
Sinir hücreleri arasındaki bağlantılar
Arthur sadece kimyasal olmakla kalmıyor
beynin farklı bölgeleri ise yazma
merkezler okuma var düşünme var yüz
tanıma Merkez var müziği bir Merkez var
bile şehirleri gibi onunla arasındaki
bağlantılar kendi beynim yapısı
değişiyor ya öğrenme ve bellek bu
şekilde de kısa süreli bebeğimiz var
uzun süreli gönderiniz Siz kısa süreli
bellekte bir telefon numarasını
aklınızda tutmanız gerekir O altın için
önemlidir işte bir yer arayacaksınız ama
işiniz bittiğinde onu birşeyde
ilişkilendirme sizseniz şurada
gösterdiğim bu hard diskiniz onu
atmıyorsun uçup gidiyor Ama herkes başka
bir şey de ilişkilendirebilirsiniz uzun
belli yapıyorsunuz ve sadece Kimya
devam etmekte kalmıyorsunuz beyninizin
yapısını değiştiriyorsunuz Bu yüzden
kendi beynim Ne kadar Nereye gitmek
istiyorsanız beynimizin hangi bölgesini
geliştirmek istiyorsanız Ayna fitness'a
gidenler işte egzersiz yapıp bir
sebzedir seslerini gelişini insanlar
gibi hangi bölgeye çalışmak istiyorsanız
o bölgeyi geliştiriyorsunuz